le film que je recommande et huit places
du réalisateur franco-américain Damien
Chazel
ce que je trouve formidable dans ce film
c'est déjà à quel point il nous immerge
dans cet univers musical
[Musique]
ou c'est le jazz qui est mis au cœur de
la Seine
[Musique]
aussi ce film mais vraiment en scène ce
jeune batteur avec en quelque sorte son
double plus expérimenté plus âgé avec
lequel il vit un rite de passage qui par
certains côtés peut ressembler à une
histoire d'amour puisqu'ils vivent des
obstacles des disputes et une certaine
forme de partage artistique Damien
Chazel est un réalisateur que j'admire
beaucoup et ce film a un travail sur la
lumière notamment je pense à la lumière
qui est travaillée dans le cadre de donc
cette scène de concert pour représenter
les différents rôles entre les musiciens
et aussi le rite de passage de ce jeune
batteur j'ai trouvé que c'était vraiment
un travail absolument époustouflant et
on reconnaît bien la pâte de Damien
Chazel avec le travelling et les
mouvements de la caméra qui sont
absolument unique en son genre
[Musique]